[Music]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app
[Music]
congratulations episode and I don't do
it like I don't do it like how guys do
it like this is episode yada yada
congratulations and welcome to my
podcast I say all the words and I just
throw them out there and you guys pick
the [ __ ] make the sentence about it
cuz I don't give a [ __ ] okay and that's
how it's gonna be and that's fine and
because you need you need that you need
you need a guy like that in your life
and that's me and so today we have
another we have a guest our second guest
but it's really our first guest because
you know it did so well last time and
he's my brother and we have Matt daliyah
here on the podcast mm-hmm and so Matt
Delhi is here now first of all actually
before we even do that I'm gonna being
[ __ ] San Diego or some [ __ ] go get
tickets you know it's so [ __ ] blase
about it because I don't you know
because they can come if they want but
but hey by the way have you ever been to
San Diego I've been to San Diego yeah
where I've been to San Diego with you
we're at the we went to the [ __ ] I
went down there one week and when you at
the Comedy Store there there's a comedy
store there yeah you did yeah yeah we
were in that weird [ __ ] blue room
that they put people up in and [ __ ]
remember that yeah yeah that was a long
time wait you came yeah yeah is there I
was with who with you you were there
yeah and I know I was you were there
well I actually don't even remember I
don't even know if I don't I don't even
remember who else was there
what you don't remember who was on the
show you and and other was I headlining
or was it oh no I think it was earlier
than that yeah Wow Jesus God I have the
worst [ __ ] oh yeah it was that guy
Brandon I had no [ __ ] it the British
guy remember [ __ ] who used to bring
his own microphone at the guitar guy
[ __ ] the guy that he did the
Wonderwall thing yep that [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] funny and stupid Wow
were you there oh he was there two one
fire was there okay cool yeah one fire
was there all right so all right cool
Wow [ __ ] that's right oh yeah I missed
that guy I haven't talked to him in a
long time anyway nobody knows what the
[ __ ] were talking about but there is a
comedy store in La Jolla and we went to
do that this is the only time to be in
San Diego maybe do you know San Diego
sucks I did know that yeah for sure when
I went there I was like this the thing
about this place yeah is that it [ __ ]
sucks
is what I remember that thing is is that
there's just bros and and it's just it's
a weird mixture of people but I'm just
it's very beautiful though it's very
pretty but it's like you're in a frat
yeah yeah when you go yeah automatic and
the crowds are [ __ ] bonkers dude so
yeah I believe that I know it's a I'll
never go back again and then when I go
and then I end up going because I have
to do the [ __ ] thing because it's I
want to make money you lying to yourself
or you say it out loud to other people I
say it I say it and I think you know
what I'm never gonna go back and then
time passes and I think well I guess
let's make money and go there right
right I mean there's a line in [ __ ] a
Tupac song and I always think about it
and he said and they're talking about
exhibit because exhibit made a song
about not making not not making not
doing rap for money and about doing it
for the you know love of it or whatever
and and then there's a guy one of the
outlaws in the Tupac song says if you
ain't in it for the money then what the
[ __ ] is your purpose mane and I always
think about that in regards to my life
and it and it's so silly that I think
about one of the outlaws and then I'm
like yeah I gotta [ __ ] do this to
make the money even though that's not
why I do it but basically I'm one of the
outlaws is what I'm saying I think that
yeah I think you're like one of the
outlaws are you one of the outlaws the
worst the worst interview of all time so
yeah you wanted our loss dude you know
what I don't want to do is [ __ ] the
interview but that's why I've had no no
guests so it's before you continue I'm
not one of the ass yeah so let's look at
the outlaws names first it was such a
bad interview
that you actually didn't even let me
[ __ ] answer you yeah yeah I don't
want to do that yeah yeah so nah but go
back 1 1 fire young thug's with young
thug's with the z is so [ __ ] 90s
these are the guys yaki Kadafi head
vocals you know like there's gonna be
one of them playing the drums ha ha ha
yeah I'll say vocals well et I mean I
mean et I mean II I mean mm-hmm yep oh
that's the coolest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen or it's like et I mean yeah
since 1993 he's been doing vocals young
and Noble young no well he's got a
frilly collar and [ __ ] vocals whoo Zayn
a fountain pen in his hand
who's Hussein fatal okay I wanna skip
anybody a couple there's a really good
one yeah here's another one that and I
know and this one I like and I can
always tell this was big syke so he is
in a lot of is he's in a lot of the he's
in the hola homey that cyclic big syke
got yeah or like big psycho no III think
it's big psycho even though it's spelled
sy ke but of course it is cuz rap right
right here he's in this song he's the
one you're gonna you're gonna he's the
one who is this guy what about go back
to laughing that is so [ __ ] insecure
the big one I think he's saying
something but he's this guy
big steak oh that's what he's [ __ ]
saying I mean I thought he was laughing
so [ __ ] I don't know not clear you
know no no no the best laugh is a did
you even hear that one yeah yeah I
didn't even hear that well that's like
the cute insecure thing a he's like but
he's got the finger up to his mouth look
[Music]
it's not even part of what he's saying
he came in it was like I want to do a
cute one yeah yeah did you get the cute
one in there yeah but no oh god like
he's eating up eating a candy bar little
cookies eating a little company yeah a
Miss a Miss cookie there's Castro with a
K yeah of course vocals from 1993 to
2009 after that he was like you know
what [ __ ] it I'm retiring hanging up the
Spurs and there's just straight-up
Napoleon that's my favorite one yeah cuz
he didn't even try didn't spell it wrong
the Spelling's right they all so many of
them have like legendary terrible men
name yes yes yes well over saying
because they're badass Qaddafi et I mean
yeah that's where young noble really
sticks out he's like a good guy right
yeah true yeah
Napoleon did nope vocals from 1993 to
2003 mopreme shakur I believe mopreme
yeah yeah okay well that's dumb that I
said that cuz it's a mice to him he was
related to him I think it was a costume
his name was Momo deep reme I don't know
if that's his real name or what but
that's pretty unbelievable mopreme
alright Maurice yeah okay go back let's
go back back
stormy vocals for only six years really
he came late Oh Sean Cole I don't know
that guy he's been voting for one
[ __ ] year yeah mmm the storm two
years and then there is Musa Musa mil
Metamucil and if we do so or not vocals
for like one month maybe
it says 1996 1996 that kicked the [ __ ]
out and then there was new child 96 96 I
think new child was a I think new child
was maybe a girl I don't that looks like
a guy
because he has a beard no there's nobody
no picture for new child oh that's
[ __ ] stormy there's so many of them
um yeah I'm getting jailed here yeah so
so so yeah so oh my god Jesus Christ
Pasolini deceased Lau a lot of them are
dead who st. fatal naka Valley well
that's too that's too far yeah yeah you
know he died did it I heard that okay so
anyway it's the congrat career at par
cast congratulations and we always like
to start by talking about slain members
of the outlaws but uh yeah man it's
crazy actually how many rappers have
died and also keep dying that's actually
[ __ ] insane and we're not going to
get into that so that's it
so I have Matt Thalia here and the one
of the reasons why I have Matt Tilley is
well the main reason why is because I
love him right you know and another
reason is why because that the podcast
that he was on the episode did really
well people like to hear us together and
another reason why is because you
started a podcast and it's out now I did
yeah I did and it's out now and it's
called Matt alia it's confused
yup and but don't go like that don't be
like yo yo yo yeah cuz it's infuriating
and so and so the artwork that you have
on your podcast is very cool I really
like that it captures you thank you I
like it more than my podcast art that
makes my tea is actually I do too okay
well I didn't know here's the thing if
you had your podcast out first I would
make sure my art works better but I
didn't know you're gonna do a podcast
when I started I'm 130 episodes in you
are yeah so I would I actually thought
about changing it when I saw yours
like to try to one-up my not not even
know just to be like oh if his is gonna
be that good I gotta step my level up
like I don't care if yours is better but
it can't be that much better you know
what I mean
that's annoying to me yeah yeah the art
is good look at that [ __ ] ya know what
is the thing on the right I was just
what I what what what what is oh that's
like a [ __ ] firing yes because I'm so
confused yeah got you magically is
confuse the whole thing is like I have
guests on unlike you I have actual
guests yeah and I have people on that
can like talk about [ __ ] that confuses
me and clear [ __ ] up for me or [ __ ] that
is like funny you're [ __ ] crazy right
every guest like can kind of color in
something that sort of yells me about
the [ __ ] world and well and I don't
want to talk you know this isn't like a
[ __ ] I don't it sounds like I'm
interviewing you I'm not but I actually
haven't asked you this yet or even told
it's a telling you thing uh uh how come
you're so good at what you consciously
do do you consciously okay so like take
like I've heard maybe four episodes now
and over there 5 out 5 they feel like
yeah yeah yeah I think I've heard three
or four so how do you not mad brother
bad brother but yeah okay no but that's
a good brother by the way I shouldn't
listen to all of them but yeah okay well
so I didn't yet but that's a good
brother because I've listened to [ __ ]
most of them and I'm gonna listen to all
of them okay so so by the way do you
remember the [ __ ] thing when the guy
was like oh yeah dude I think about that
all the [ __ ] time
yeah it was an infomercial I go back to
what I was gonna say yes a compliment
isn't it no I don't so just be ready for
it I'm ready
so there's a [ __ ] infomercial and we
would watch infomercials all the time
and we and when we were like we do we
live together yeah yeah hold on before
you go we would watch infomercials so
[ __ ] much and so late and you were so
[ __ ] annoying about making me do it
yeah well because it is so fun for me I
no no I got it but I would do it and I'd
be like 3:00 a.m. I just feel like my
eyes would be so [ __ ] heavy yeah and
you we would be pissing our pants
laughing but yeah yeah it would be me
you and like a lot of live it like five
guys yeah I remember Dave Miller we
lived at Five Guys the burger place and
no we lived with five guys with Dave
Miller there was it was Chris Paul mmm
our other buddy Chris mock oh and then
other guys too I feel like I don't know
there's a role I don't know whatever we
were in our 20s
you looked out
young noble and no and and and we would
just make fun of informers and we but
laugh so hard it's one of my favorite
things because they the the one of the
reasons why I like inform us of so much
is because I know everybody on it is
absolutely [ __ ] lying
yeah they're better they know it and we
know it and also everybody knows it
everybody but everybody is watching this
like it's not [ __ ]
yeah like they'll be like it is just the
best product and they know it's not
because you see that same guy selling
that product selling another product
that's saying this is the best product
yeah so there was one that was like I'm
a get make money get rich thing and he
was like and I've made a lot of money
and we laughed so hard because he
whispered it for effect and now we
always say oh yeah he was being such a
[ __ ] prick yeah he was being like I
make money right and like it's so much
I'm kinda like this yeah yeah yeah it
was like when Jay Z's rapping he's like
yeah you know and when he goes to that
for a fact he was like you know to meet
Cassandra man like that kind of [ __ ] he
was like basically doing the jay-z of
infomercials so anyway what I was gonna
say yeah about that about you
mmm the the Idi Amin of infomercials is
you are really I don't because I'm
listening cuz cuz I'm self-centered I'm
listening to your podcast and I'm
thinking how would I do this mmm-hmm
yeah I I could not do it and I'm
surprised you can do this because it's a
it's great to do this mmm-hmm that you
can do it with some of the guests you
don't believe a word they're [ __ ] so
right rather you don't believe in a word
they're saying yeah it's not like you
think they're lying
yeah right right yeah you don't you
don't call them out on it yeah and you
don't even really I know cuz I'm your
brother I can hear you be like okay and
I know you think they're crazy yeah
maybe yeah or whatever but I I would be
like the whole time I would just be
going oh yeah you know what I mean the
whole time I'd be like well the crazy
thing about that is it's absolutely not
true or so now what right but you
don't do that right I mean and and you
don't do that consciously that's the
kind of the point for me like the
easiest example is we had this famous
Exorcist this dude Bob Larson who by the
way if you don't know who that is look
up his videos it's [ __ ] really is
amazing it's insane but he's like
obviously to be an extra you have to
believe in a lot of [ __ ] that like well
I certainly don't believe in you know
the thing is it's like I'm interested in
that guy right
so what I didn't what I don't want to do
with any guests is be like will you
believe that that's Donald for any
judgment on for first of all because I
want to know more and that's gonna close
him up but also like the whole thing for
me is like I don't I'm not trying to
like get you I'm not trying like the nru
and make you look dumb and in doing that
they'll talk about way more [ __ ] like
that episode is called sexually
transmitted demons because he believes
there's a thing called sexually
transmitted demons right we talked about
that for like 10 or 15 minutes and you
know hit for sure but it's totally yeah
III but but I think it's very
interesting as well I I mean I would say
I I think it's interesting I mean I
would watch those videos on you too but
I I guess maybe it's why I'm a comedian
I can't I can't not make fun of it yeah
right I mean I just can't yeah like I
would I I would laugh you don't even
really like laugh like I would laugh I
couldn't help myself
yeah I would laugh in their face yeah
and and and and I wouldn't but I
wouldn't want them but I also wouldn't
want them to feel stupid
right but so maybe that would make them
feel stupid I would want them to like I
love I love don't get me wrong dude I
make fun of a lot of [ __ ] on this
podcast yeah and I would make fun of Bob
Larson on this faux fur yeah but I love
that there is a Bob Larson and I love
that he's doing that and I would not
want to live in a world where there
isn't a Bob Larson yeah that doesn't do
that yeah yeah so yeah I mean I just
like like kind of what you're saying I
like that exists yeah to me it's like a
show you know uh-huh
like if I if I if I thought too much
about it it would maybe like make me
[ __ ] cry or Colin Rowe and think
about how these people believe
the ship but it's really ultimately just
so [ __ ] absurd right that I like it
you know so do you think so Bob Larson
is this Exorcist that has been doing it
for [ __ ] 50 40 years he's been doing
for 40 years he's done it he says at
least 40,000 yeah yeah I heard that so
and also which is that yeah it's very
it's very that but also do you think I
always wonder if guys like yeah he
absolutely believes in it oh dude he
this wasn't we don't even have video of
yep we're gonna end up doing radio soon
but he with him has a [ __ ] big cross
and a Bible that he always has with him
I don't know if it's because like his
some Exorcist [ __ ] there's gonna like
crop up at any given moment but it's
just like got it with them it was on the
table between us it's like all of a
sudden you're gonna be so Bob Larson I
have a question give you some baloney so
go give me the buy cars give me my cross
exactly yeah
so but that didn't happen he didn't have
[ __ ] to me I didn't have a demon yeah
but everyone well he says everyone
should get an exorcism whether you get
it or not which is a businessman yeah if
you don't believe he like he was to make
money anyway even though he believes in
he's like I can also make some money
yeah I mean you do the [ __ ] thing
that's the thing I like about him yeah
just showman yeah yeah yeah I believe in
this ship but also gotta make a living
right
right like I'm on his newsletter and
there was a thing he was trying like a
raise money yeah like kidney stones like
a thing like some operation you needed
to do yes like God needs you you know
cuz I gotta keep doing it you know
that's like that wow that's like the
version of me doing a [ __ ] corporate
gig is a comedian or something we're
doing a wedding I've never done a
wedding but I've heard like I don't know
comedians do weddings and [ __ ] yeah yeah
I somebody so tell me the other day that
Jim Jefferies like they were like he got
hired and him like a crazy amount of
money you know these rich people and
he's like alright I'll do it but but
it's weird too because like when you
when you as a comedian like you'll get
hard for these [ __ ] things that don't
you don't know you're like they'll be
like we we don't you know we want that
guy but they don't know the act yeah
they want like I've been hired in a
corporate gig in Las Vegas for this I
don't even
company but I was hired because the the
guy who ran the company son was a big
fan now the guy was older the son was
probably 30-something but the guy was
like [ __ ] 60 in his 60s and I'm like
I don't know if this guy knows what I
talk about like right this is his
company's my son's come right yeah so
like a bunch of older guys it went fine
but you never know you never know how
that's gonna [ __ ] go there must be so
[ __ ] they think they hire you and
they think Oh a comedian he's gonna be
like Paul Reiser yeah you know and I'm
not up there and I'm not up there
talking about socks right right you know
how come you ever miss match your socks
and [ __ ] Paul Reiser yeah yeah they're
like you ever [ __ ] you ever put the
wrong thing with the wrong thing in the
car and then you know the worst bit of
[ __ ] fault I'm Paul Reggie a oh okay
do you remember [ __ ] the Sony hack
[ __ ] no oh yeah yeah of course I
remember that yeah Paul Reiser's emails
from that oh I'd never seen it never got
about this or straight up the saddest
[ __ ] nothing's ever yet it he's like
where's my money from mad about you
residuals no I've never seen this before
my like there are a lot of DVDs in the
world where's my money and it's like
it's 2016 dude your show was on and
really when he was talking about DVDs
look 2014 yeah oh he wrote this - if
your agent do it yeah that's well see
the problem is when you get that big
like he was very big he knows everybody
and he has everybody Seamon he's like
I'm just gonna reach out myself and do
it the old-school way which is a
horrible idea
so wait yeah okay almost yeah this is
this is I never read I never heard this
I didn't remember it being like a
[ __ ] epic poem this is like the
longest [ __ ] email ever well go out
go out go up let's see a little bit of
it hope this finds you well last time I
saw you I think it was in the lobby of
the Moscow Moscow hotel which was just
nuts you know it's gonna be sad I was
just going to say that exact sentence
right that and you know it's gonna be
sad because usually present parentheses
and and a [ __ ] and the exhibition
trying to make it like we're good we're
good
yeah now here comes the [ __ ] back
door here comes this sad and [ __ ] anyway
I'm writing just to tell you about the
great meeting I had yesterday with your
people that and
here at the and you know it's not that
yeah not sure if you even know about
this but I had been trying for the
longest time to try and get some clarity
as to why Matt about you was not
available on it's entirely entirety
season six and seven were never released
on DVD at all
iTunes offers only season three and
seasons that by the fact that he even
knows all that don't even know it don't
even know it yeah you know very
difficult to find I had not even known
any of this until I started performing
on the road again over the last two
years and people just have to ask me why
they couldn't get the season okay so
that's how I found out apparently there
was no more than a few people out there
who want these shows sure there's a big
big big show and it was very fun it was
really as I remember yeah anyway turns
out music clearance issues seem to be
the problem okay
that's sure so yesterday along with into
my attorney and a longtime producer okay
I met with you okay geez autism business
[ __ ] they were terrifically helpful and
alright I told them that my recollection
comedic lead distorted I'm sure yeah
help us get to show out there so my hope
is that you can once again use your
magic wand and help us get the show out
there as I explained to the group
yesterday my motivation here is not
financial though if we could I mean yeah
it is dude yeah the truth is I just
wanted to rectify the crazy-making
situation which we yeah it's got to be
financial right uh yeah maybe he wants
to be I mean he thinks like it'll be
like a friends thing yeah but that's not
gonna happen yeah it's just to make it
available on iTunes yeah true yeah true
very and latest hacker releases one of
the most depressing emails you'll ever
read from man wondering why more people
can buy his ninety six home yeah yeah I
progress I always liked Paul Reiser I
always thought I was a fan of his it's
like always like from diner and even mad
about you I thought was [ __ ]
hilarious yeah I like Paul Ryan I think
he's good I haven't seen him in a bit
but a guys like that like I don't know
he was also a good actor his good and
[ __ ] yeah what's he like I don't know
what he's doing now I see him I see him
I know he was in that movie whiplash oh
it was yeah yeah he plays miles teller
wasn't he in like [ __ ] alien and
alien to alien
yeah like aliens I was rad in [ __ ]
alien yeah like he's like he just kind
of made money and then [ __ ] bounced I
feel like because he not enough though
he needs the
and mad about you citizen but he's
probably got money I mean he's only 62
dude it's it's not like he's 70 [ __ ]
eight you know you can still do a lot of
[ __ ] it's not like you were like where's
gene equity you're like always 90 become
any like romance things he was yeah
bye-bye love
well honestly he was the marrying man
yeah but a worst [ __ ] title there
ever [ __ ] was the marrying man but
honestly he I mean you know he really
was really romantic but the that's the
most Paul Reiser thing that could ever
happen what what he's wearing yeah at
least I know bye-bye love
well by the way because also remember
like dude this would even annoy me when
I was 12 when they made a movie with the
title of a [ __ ] popular song yeah
yeah it would be like if I [ __ ] it
would be like if I would start in a
movie right now called ambitions as a
rider right well I don't think people
know that's a soupçon as much but like
like yesterday when yesterday just came
up yeah but that's that's which is still
different cuz it's about the Beatles
right but [ __ ] that though really oh
yeah I don't think that I don't think
[ __ ] that well cuz it's about the
Beatles but the truth is [ __ ] that well
no I mean [ __ ] that movie and its entire
really you've seen it oh yeah oh really
oh yeah why why is [ __ ] why [ __ ] it I
think that sounds like a good idea I
told you I had that idea right here's
the thing okay not to [ __ ] [ __ ] on
you yeah you had the idea to know well
everyone in the [ __ ] world ever has
had that idea what idea what exact idea
that idea about yesterday the idea of
like what if there was a world where the
[ __ ] this didn't exist and the whole
joke is jut the whole movies just like
that joke over everyone's had that idea
yeah man including you I thought about
what if there was no I wanted to make a
movie about what if there was no Andrew
Dice Clay and way better yeah well I
didn't see yesterday but and a guy like
was like found out that that was a thing
and then he was injured and he took his
act mm-hmm and then he was like this
[ __ ] hack like hey you know and
everyone's like well this is amazing
yeah yeah I really didn't think out the
idea that well but it's already better
than yesterday Wow yeah all right
the thing that annoyed me the most about
yesterday was like we also have the
[ __ ] look there are other things that
the world doesn't have to like
cigarettes
yeah and coke yeah you know really like
yesterday yeah yeah yeah
why and spoiler alert again I'm very
[ __ ] n skip ahead 15 seconds a big
big joke yeah
is that also Harry Potter didn't exist
oh wow I didn't see the movie that
sounds [ __ ] horrible it's a really
stupid [ __ ] yeah okay all right look
we're gonna go we're gonna cut we're
gonna go take a commercial break here
for for two seconds any you know we'll
be back when we do we got to do some ads
or whatever the [ __ ] I gotta make money
dude I mean I can't just [ __ ] be
doing this podcast for free so we're
gonna do some ads right now okay and it
will be back in two seconds goat you
guys tried this app goat it's great
Easy's Jordans off lights all the shoes
you want if you're gonna buy sneakers
from a few hundred for a few hundred
dollars how can you be sure they're the
real thing I've gone I've used goat I
got a some Jordans off goat that were
very cool and you know my shoe guy and
I've got I've got a bunch of stuff off
good actually and it always is authentic
they checked themselves goat calm is the
safest way to buy and sell authentic
sneakers online they're the largest
market place in the world for authentic
Easy's Jordans and over 600,000 sneaker
listings they've made the whole process
frictionless and trustworthy this how
they do this they only accept two
sellers with the best reputation by Vera
and and they also verify their sneakers
to ensure their authenticity for buyers
every detail is inspected and over half
a million sneakers on the platform 10
million users you won't find better
prices or verified 100% authentic
sneakers anywhere else find the product
find the perfect 100% authentic sneaker
at Goat calm / Congrats that's geo 80
go.com / Congrats plus you'll be
supporting our show and that's a good
thing if you're a true baby but you've
got to go right now before the sneakers
you want are gone when you go to go calm
/ Congrats spelled Geo 80 go Geo 80 calm
/ Congrats
shipstation when you're selling online
getting your orders out can be a real
pain it can be time-consuming expensive
so many carriers to choose from how do
you know you're making the best choice
that's why you need shipstation calm
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders shipstation helps you get orders
out quickly save money on shipping costs
and keep your customers happy no matter
where you're selling Amazon Etsy your
own website shipstation brings all your
orders into one simple interface making
them really easy to manage from any
device even your cell phone shipstation
works with all of the major carriers
including USPS FedEx UPS even Amazon
Fulfillment so you can compare and
choose from the best shipping solution
for you and your customer they even
offer big discounts on shipping cost
it's great right now congratulations
with Chris D'Elia listeners can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use promo code Congrats there's
absolutely no risk and you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info and that's a bonus
for me because I hate when they ask for
my numbers just visit shipstation com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Congrats
that's shipstation comm then enter promo
code congrats shipstation dot-com make
ship happen expressvpn internet privacy
is basically dead we all knew that look
at porn for instance did you know that
the UK government passed a law requiring
you to hand over your ID before you can
access porn sites oh oh or should I say
oh that's right like your driver's
license or passport it's not it's only a
matter of time before your government
gets the same idea so great and what
happens when your favorite porn site
gets hacked like Ashley Madison dead all
those names and IDs will be floating
around waiting to get published on the
web that's why I protect my internet
usage with expressvpn accessing the
internet with expressvpn means the
websites you visit won't know where
you're coming for
shielding your identity Express Express
VPN is the best way to make your online
activity anonymous and it's the VPN
provider I trust to protect my data in
fact I use expressvpn every time I go
online just in case so you should to
download the Express VPN app on your
computer or phone push one button and
voila you're protected or if you're dumb
viola you're protected for less than
seven dollars a month you might be like
eyes gotta be [ __ ] there's gonna be
seven thousand dollars no it's not for
less than seven dollars a month you can
get the same expressvpn protection that
I have expressvpn is rated the number
one VPN service by TechRadar and comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee it's
time to stop Big Brother and
surveillance of your online activity
protect yourself today and find out how
you can get three months free at
expressvpn comm / Congrats that expr ESS
VPN as in nice dot-com / congrats for
three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn dot-com /
Congrats to learn more congratulations
is brought to you by the cash app the
app that likes when you pet it yeah so
you didn't like that okay well so you
see every movie though I try to see
every movie and it's hard I've seen
bye-bye love I've never seen bye-bye
love okay well you have to add that to
you I should see whether I love ya how
do you edit a Bible in there I should
see a pop-up I love but and it's
instinct yeah so so wait I was going so
say something else to you I don't know I
don't remember I guess we're done [ __ ]
it no uh-oh oh I told you this I wanted
to this chick came up to me when I was
at the [ __ ] coffee bean I was killing
now I was drinking an iced americano you
know always doing that yeah yeah so but
sometimes I get three shots over ice but
at coffee bean they kind of do a good
iced americano now here's the thing this
girl came up to me and she was like hey
I'm a I'm such a big fan I'm so nervous
okay but I'm such a big fan and I just
wanted to tell you that and I said oh my
god thank you so much that's so sweet of
you
she was very sweet I was all smiles and
I was like that's amazing mm-hmm and and
she was like and she was like yeah I
actually ran into you a a few months ago
and you even held the door open for me
and I always thought it was so sweet so
you're a really sweet guy gentlemen yeah
I was like ah well you know what I was
like hey I guess you caught me on a good
day
right oh yeah so she says oh ho I caught
you on a good okay you're like oh oh wow
cool walks away goes back to her seat
she's back at her seat and I'm drinking
my iced americano you know now it's half
half done
I'm well I think I'm wait for my buddy
to get there yeah yeah and and then I
hear from over my shoulder at her seat I
guess I caught you on a good day oh
she's like harping on and I say and I
turn around and I say yeah her whatever
you know I don't know and she says
you're an [ __ ] just like that yeah
and I said what and she says I guess I
caught you on a good day I was like yeah
you know like you know like I was just I
don't know I literally I'm I I pride
myself and kind of always at least
saying something that keeps the
conversation going
bro I had no clue what to say and I just
kind of turned around and went back to
my iced americano
and I was like Jesus Christ
did she stay like she sat the whole time
she was there the whole time yeah she
stayed she was like 10 10 15 feet away
from me I pride myself on like knowing
what little mean when they're [ __ ] in
sin yeah yeah I don't even have a yeah I
guess on that one I don't know either I
don't know either
there is a that's a funny story as it is
okay just because you know I didn't add
anything to it just the fact that it
happened was funny right there are few
things that
I didn't say about that happening make
it a way different story
oh this is like some night Shyamalan
ashram exactly yeah or at the end was
like I thought okay and guess what also
there's no Harry Potter in the world
over that so she said she had a really
severe like physical condition like she
had a a walker and she was like so so so
this is why you held the door open now
this yes and yes so I'm not that much of
a gentleman it wasn't even that good of
a day it was just like you you can't not
open a door for someone who maybe I
don't remember I don't remember right
okay
so she probably could have got out
herself didn't have to do it no yes I
didn't have to do it but but maybe it
seemed you don't you dog you maybe it's
nicer that I did it I don't worry right
yeah maybe I play got up out of my seat
to do it I don't know I'm not trying to
say I'm a good guy but what I am saying
you're adding parts that you don't even
remember now you're right ragging about
being a nice guy right aren't you even
maybe true
yeah yeah yes so do you so I do that
made it more confusing or less confusing
I don't know because I don't know I was
like and this is now this is why maybe
I'm a bad guy I'm like well does she
just not know because is is or does this
get me in trouble but like it's also her
mind affected by this like is it not
just a physical sure yeah yeah so maybe
maybe now I'm like maybe she doesn't
know the saying because of her she
doesn't know the saying but that could
be regardless of either way she's so
[ __ ] demented till likes it I did it
when you texted me because you told me I
didn't tell you the part about the thing
I didn't know the part that there was a
gap between you you telling her that her
being an [ __ ] a ver part stories
imagining her stewing about that and
like unable to do semenya good things
yeah or innocuous so do you think that
because of her physical handicap that
has nothing to do with it that's the
thing I didn't know I think her physical
handicap has not has nothing to do with
it yeah I mean I don't think it may it
may be does but my sense is that look
I'm always like
my interactions with people throughout
the course of the day I'm constantly
thinking people are [ __ ] demented
yeah like well Bob Larson demented
people but even non exorcists right
[ __ ] demented you know I mean they'll
figure out ways to get offended yeah
they'll figure out ways to misconstrue
right what you're doing or just be
really [ __ ] rude for no reason at all
and that's part of the reason I wanted
to do my podcast is everything coozes me
about everything everyone's always doing
yeah that is a great [ __ ] example
yeah so you have her on the podcast yeah
get her get her in so I also here's like
the comedian in me which is like so
shitty like the but I I didn't make this
joke but I thought about if I did make
this joke it would be shitty when she
was came up to me she was um so nervous
and I was like and this is such a bad
joke but I was like I was like [ __ ] and
if the fact that even thought it made me
feel bad but I was like I wonder if she
wasn't as nervous if she would be
shaking less dinner I'm saying yes I do
know what just and that the fact that I
thought that I felt awful
yeah don't feel bad though yeah yeah
because I actually thought because I
actually thought I wonder because she
was like oh my god I'm shaking she was
like do it you liked you so much yeah
and you saying caught me on a good day
yeah made her go from being a supreme
mega fan yeah calling you an [ __ ]
yeah to you yeah true yeah that's
[ __ ] the biggest like a leap yeah to
go from loving you to think it was just
such a weird [ __ ] thing because like
I felt bad for her I wanted her to be
okay hmm
I wanted you know well there's your
problem right there you shouldn't feel
bad for anybody anybody I don't think so
you can feel it but like you can't put
it out in the [ __ ] world you know I
mean right well I wasn't like oh okay
well you know right you know you did
open a door for her though yeah you know
I don't know man I thought thing like I
just like but the problem is the problem
is like then I started thinking about
like
the world we live in and like God forbid
like I said what I just said on Twitter
yeah they'll be awful dry yeah it
wouldn't be funny it's not funny that I
thought that you know I just
but I'd but it but as a comedian you
think of all these bad jokes and you
sift them out right and then the
difference between like burying yourself
on Twitter and not is just literally
typing the stuff and putting it in the
world because everyone has those [ __ ]
up thought oh yeah yeah you know yeah I
mean if everyone was always saying what
was coming into their mind every single
person would be have to be in like a
mental institution you know but isn't
that but isn't that but but that [ __ ]
makes me lose that's crazy to me which
part of it like that you can just think
a thought yeah that that everyone's
thought this [ __ ] yeah
but if you write it on Twitter you're
you're [ __ ] done yeah you're done
you're literally done we all think [ __ ]
that if we wrote it on Twitter we're
[ __ ] done right especially it's like
a [ __ ] celebrity sure done yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we should just we should
just say a bunch of those my family I
think that yeah well no yeah no I think
that it's I literally think that one day
like the Sony hack [ __ ] right
everything's just gonna come out yeah
you said that before yeah like you're
gonna have the day where I wanted to
make a [ __ ] TV show about this and I
didn't I didn't ever pitch it but I
wanted it to be about like the day that
that happens
everybody's [ __ ] email and texts and
everything is just available because
that day's gonna happen yeah I agree
yeah and and and then we're going to
live in a very different world yeah
because people like legitimately Barack
Obama yeah yeah are the keys I mean
there's no way he hasn't texted like let
me see her today yeah and and guaranteed
barack obama has texted at least once
let me see your tip of course
yeah you know yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's gonna have to change everyone's
judgment of everyone out yeah yeah for
sure you know
looking up to like oh let me see your
titties yeah [ __ ] now folks folks let me
see your titties in an orgy with just a
[ __ ] button down and a tie and a
blazer and no pants it's not time to
take the whole [ __ ] thing off the
[ __ ] Obama so [ __ ] worst joke even worse
than the [ __ ] off-color joke that I
didn't do right I mean the things that
you're talking about the things that we
think about in conversation that just
put into our minds yeah oh they'll often
be like violent for me mmm yeah like
with you I'll be like thinking about
like ripping your throat out that
brother and it's alright but bad brother
but I don't do ever thought that about
you by the way and it's all good okay
well now I feel bad yeah even though I
shouldn't but like but it's right
honestly honestly it's probably because
you're my younger brother and I'm your
older brother because you well let's not
psychoanalyze no you know because I feel
like I there is a part of me where I
feel like I would take care of you no
matter what oh that's because you're my
younger brother honestly you're making
me feel so [ __ ] bad and so I'll just
like if you want one no no it's okay
because you want to kill me because
that's a that's a [ __ ] things go
forward younger brothers happy yeah they
want to be the [ __ ] and I get it okay
now chill out though I would let you
that's it now how bad do you feel
definitely chill out though but like
even like just like if I'm like ordering
a [ __ ] bagel you know like like what
if I just like I want to like spit in
this person's face mm-hmm you know just
a constant barrage of that right barrage
Obama barrage Obama
folks I want to spit in your face yeah
why is he southern when you do it folks
why is he on king of the hill it's and I
want to spit in your face so um oh boy
it's a hot one Anna I want to put ting
so I know that's mine yeah that's acidic
the guy from pleased Academy so no that
guy was around yeah yeah by the way
let's just say right now there was no
one greater in the 80s or 90s then
whoever that guy was who did all the
sounds in police academy and that's it
and we're not talking about it yeah I
mean please gotta miss so much great
[ __ ] you'll have to do Oh
Proctor I'm that [ __ ] dude I just made
fun of this last night on stage I just
[ __ ] talked about this last night on
stage the the
the the the the mic was buzzing when I
was onstage and it wouldn't stop and I
got the guy I was like yo can you fix
this and they had to literally bring a
ladder onstage to go up while I'm on
stage to go up and unplug a speaker so
it would stop buzzing and when he got on
the ladder it kind of like felt back a
little bit and I was like a [ __ ] John
Candy movie like like I was like like
you remember in the 80s when they would
like do [ __ ] and they wouldn't stop
themselves they'd be like whoa keep
holding on the ladder you just let go oh
and then I brought up like the [ __ ]
where you'd be like I have to tell you
something and he'd be like Proctor not
now you know any like but I have to and
then you get hit in the head with an
anvil and I just said that on [ __ ]
stage last night yeah those police
academy movies are the Shh Michael
Winslow was the guy but yeah Michael
wins though and he was the belle of know
Michael wins always together he would
just go like no reason character was
yeah the [ __ ] Lavelle larvell Jones
yeah Michael wins those guys [ __ ]
rules
so hey by the way you know a white guy
wrote the script and [ __ ] named the
character larvell and that's racist
so larvell yeah Carvel yeah I guess or
like larva okay and then but then
remember the [ __ ] David Graf go back
go back you go too far one fire yeah so
too far right now he's going too far
right he went to flare that makes us mad
you don't win 24 to fast
so David Graf Eugene tackleberry
remember when he [ __ ] held the gun to
the shark and the shark swam away
tackleberry and Hightower were like the
badass one yeah and then Steve
Guttenberg do it let me just say that's
right I'm gonna agree to it Steve
Guttenberg's face yeah dude okay I was
so ready to agree I don't know you're
gonna say yeah I [ __ ] agree no Steve
Guttenberg's face Steve Guttenberg face
yeah looks like Seaver looks like he's
wearing a Steve Guttenberg face dude
look how rad look at that [ __ ] no I'll
do it Steve Guttenberg the picture that
you have with the [ __ ] purple that's
soso side behind it dude that guy the
devil and Steve Guttenberg that is
article i'd read i prioritize reading
that article over almost anything you
know steve guttenberg gets so mad he
blacks out for twenty minutes it wakes
up and thinks oh god listen what were we
doing you know what else thought - well
for real his his dick
mmm hard is like three inches you know
yeah no his dick is bigger limp than it
is hot yes it like goes you're like
lands a little bit like scientists would
look at it and the yeah what's going on
yeah they could be labor the first of
all take off that mask and like it's not
a mask but Steve Guttenberg
how much is Steve Goldberg a guy that
would get into jiu-jitsu later you
[ __ ] join a jiu-jitsu class and you'd
be like oh my god Steve Greenberg Zinn
here's a [ __ ] brown belt while he's
going through divorce while he's going
through a divorce
you're like heard it's good for your
mind yes so a guy that would get into
jiu-jitsu late in life
holy [ __ ] meters of him are there with
his shirt off and [ __ ]
why is he so [ __ ] yoked there's a
video on YouTube Steve Guttenberg
shirtless he's got the raddest bottle
that ever I do
ready I knew that already every time he
took off his shirt he was so [ __ ]
shredded and also puffed it was
unbelievable huh shredded it was because
his face doesn't go with a shredded body
doesn't but it does in the 80s and
that's why yeah that's why he was so
[ __ ] famous because like he was so 80s
I mean do it he was great man what a rad
guy does he ever not smile I don't think
so like when he's sleeping he's he's got
his teeth showing right I think his rad
body I think so oh [ __ ] does it Bogle
Jiu Jitsu and Steve Guttenberg you know
I might get lucky go to Google Images
he wasn't three men and a baby which
also rules yep he did a lot of cool [ __ ]
talk about a guy that just couldn't be
famous now if he was that age now like
he would literally never get hired yeah
I know he liked you that much I was a
bit boring regular looking a white guy
like yeah good [ __ ] [ __ ] that
let me clue the [ __ ] is that yeah yeah
John Hines owner of him monkey bar Jim
dude
no Steve Guttenberg for sure I can't I
mean cuz I used to do jiu-jitsu there
would be guys that would be like [ __ ]
in the class and he would just so be one
of those guys and he would be good and
it'd be so annoying and you'd be like
hey I should be able to kick his [ __ ]
ass but it right he's also a really good
chest hair that guy yeah he does he's
also aged kind of well he looks kind of
good he just looks exactly the same
[ __ ] man what's he do there's ago him
and polarize need to do a movie about
jiu-jitsu yeah they could play like
brother will be the worst brother
ultimate that would be the worst movie
of all time if Steve Guttenberg and
[ __ ] what's his name and I Paul
Reiser movie about jiu-jitsu it late in
life I mean I would but the thing is it
would be bad but there's no way I
wouldn't watch the living [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of it look he was a short circuit so
much [ __ ] look at that there's nothing
more 80s and go down then that image
right there of that then go down look
the classic trailer go over yelling in
Wow
dude dude Louisville you know Vala bro
for no reason it will be like well we
got to get larvell on the case and then
he would just be like yeah and then they
break in the [ __ ] thing nobody do the
air that he'd walk through the airport
thing and he would do this yeah yeah
yeah I'm for no reason even as a kid I
was like dude did he get the part or did
they write the thing to find the perfect
guy let me tell you something I have
thought about that exact question yeah
for like a grand total probably of like
70 hours we can find that out it's very
easy to find that out we just find out
one of the writers and [ __ ] and but they
put they had to have written it for like
you know you know what I mean like well
maybe he got the part they were like no
no no way there's no [ __ ] day day
like I know that what the right was like
I also know this guy who could do sound
effects we could include that into the
thing right well maybe maybe he was
already big for being that gotta get the
sound guy he's probably like a comedian
ish kind of guy that would do like
sounds like an impression comedians and
but uh I was gonna say I was gonna say
something about that
oh you know what I laughed so hard at in
in in it was like police academy 6 or
one of the best many
hi big baggage they were trying to
remake that movie actually [ __ ] years I
also got you a box set of DVDs and you
definitely never [ __ ] open them and
my brother yeah oh yeah I remember you
got me yeah and you didn't open but that
was what will you polarizer by me
[ __ ] so so he so and then the big bad
guy stole ice cream and then he went to
go eat it and it fell on the on the
concrete and he says Oh crapola and I
thought that guy the jerk the
juxtaposition of him the oh this is it
is this the same oh my god this is it
let me play it let me play it what is it
cry you just literally googled crapola
nah man police academy six ice cream oh
really
but it's called crap ola oh it is yeah
crap all to hold on oh my god here it's
so high cause just everything's on line
I know always I thought was ever so
funny when I was eight look look what is
that larvell No oh yeah oh oh so angry
about it
you know what of what I've done that you
know what's so [ __ ] bad about the
scene this is the one I'm already to
disagree no no no no it's good to be
ready to agree or dishonor I agree with
that okay
but this is a mistake this is not the
script okay this is a mistake that
happened during shooting and they should
have just done it again all right what
is it I don't know if I agree dude the
actors saw s a bad yeah that he goes to
eat it yeah and then it kind of falls
off but he knows it's supposed to fall
off is it on and then and then he waits
for it but he reacts too soon watch
[Music]
coming oh boy look good watch watch also
just cut earlier when it starts to tip
you know yeah just do it again just do
it again
also we tell you what I do like about
that sequence though the close-up of the
ice cream falling is is [ __ ] rad like
that makes it to me way better yeah so
much so that while it was happening I
was like great close-up yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm low maker I'm a filmmaker - I
don't know that's what you say that one
of the my favorite things about this is
going to look at the YouTube comments is
always so funny can't believe I found
this whoever put this up thank you still
okay I remember this oh it was that guy
but that that actor [ __ ] is rad and
in so much Oh tall guy really yeah yeah
that's funny that there's other people's
favorite is the internet here's the
thing though there is no scene that you
can't find if it's from a movie you
remember whether people remember it -
and they it's online
dude hold on a second though I was just
about this
yeah that's so bad you're right dude
single boy so much by the way he's
saying old boy so much because honestly
he's such a badass right right like like
no reaction here is a matter of fact
don't watch this mm-hmm just listen
it couldn't sound more like a guy bust
them not too quick ha ha yeah oh boy oh
boy oh boy
and then the splat and then the crap
older just listen to it don't don't
watch my clothes my [ __ ] okay okay
I'm [ __ ] I'm ready
listen
[Music]
oh boy and that's him coming he came too
early that woke up all that he came to
do the oh boy oh boy is really I'm gonna
come to quickly yes and the laughing -
he's so nervous
he's so nervous but also the amount he's
out of breath like that's exactly
aligned with its cause he's so big and
walking right right right if you're that
big just walking gets you straight up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we all know
that we all know that you know so oh
sure okay wait so I'm laughing you know
I know I'm laughing I laughed so much
dude do you have to do it some people
don't we'll have it so I talked about
this in the other markets I just don't
get some people just don't laugh you
know dude laugh more everybody [ __ ]
laughed more than that people don't want
to those areas in three states so taken
so seriously that's so upsetting
I know but whatever Coppola you know I
know
total crapola but also I wanted to talk
about kind of I guess I wanted to talk
about okay well queuing on
oh [ __ ] was another person you have on
yeah I have an expert on this [ __ ]
crazy conspiracy theory you know what
you should have on your podcast though
okay this is suggest just a suggestion I
mean because here's why because it'll
fall down the microphone will fall down
so I'm putting the Batman cup on it to
profit so you've like a rigged it I've
rigged it okay
and when it falls I go crapola so no you
may get a different microphone stand but
for yeah yeah I know I bro it's [ __ ]
one fire yeah well so that's his name
now the reason so listen here's the deal
the queuing on you've had you had a Q&Q
a non-expert
yes not a researcher that knows
everything about to try to quickly
explain what qa9 is for the closure
don't know why people don't know what
the [ __ ] it is he went on is it started
as like this anonymous person posting on
I think 4chan and now it's on HN this
person claiming to be an military
insider head
whoo yeah I mean it's the most yeah sure
I'll handle the hit okay you do the hit
and I'll just run it everything that's
hey I'll just [ __ ] you
and it basically posits that it's this
person that's posting is names cue it
yeah you don't have to do okay look the
I'm just going with stop stopping mine
okay you're stopping it so I'll just do
the hit you are stopping me you're
saying don't do the thing I'm just gonna
do what I'm gonna do now but you okay
because here's the thing I have a
podcast just me and I have to do the
hits by myself great thing is for you to
just talk and all handle it I didn't
[ __ ] do that
I didn't do a single you're having all
the okay alright so this [ __ ] person
or people queue post these things right
they're like really really vague code
ish coded things that people are
convinced our clues about what they call
the coming storm and the coming storm is
going to lead to the Great Awakening
Donald Trump is going to usher in this
new era of peace and prosperity and it's
totally like a Magath Inge okay you know
and it's and it's and it's this the the
broader theory is that the millet people
certain people in the military and
Donald Trump are working together to get
rid of the deep State Clinton Obama
George Soros the Rothschilds like
anybody who anybody on the right wing
hates yeah and so there's like this
cabal that controlling the world and
Trump and these people in the military
are like taking them down yeah but every
[ __ ] prediction this Q entity has
made is whoops I know it's okay no you
can do it like this okay it's like
[ __ ] wrong right right you're never
ever right everything this thing's
always wrong it's always [ __ ] wrong
but then a Hillary Clinton being
arrested on October 18 2017 and
obviously wasn't right you know and
there but then they they say [ __ ] like
will cue the guy who leads it or
whatever will be like yeah but
disinformation is the
thing exactly that on purpose right
right yes insecure cell right right so
it's always cool to have a cabal that's
super insecure so um so so that so you
had an expert on that subject yeah on
your podcast that's very interesting I
listened to the whole thing you got
let's do it to clarify like what's up
righties how do you believe right right
this right now my suggestion is you have
to get somebody who is an absolute
member of the killa not on your right
podcast for sure you have to yeah
because that's I have to know how that
person really actually believed it in
thinks that yeah I'm going to for sure
so one thing we want to do is like we'll
have someone who's like an expert on a
thing and then who after that either a
week or a couple weeks after that we'll
have like someone who is an actual
person among that thing like like
they're the in cell culture is like
we're I talked to somebody about in so
Quran what the [ __ ] that is right well
spawn from I'm also going to talk to an
actual in cell you're gonna yeah you
plan on doing this yeah yeah yeah that's
great okay good good hell yeah the
install thing is like oh yeah it's it's
yeah that's a pretty wild thing we've
talked about that here yeah butters
isn't in cell well that's unfortunate
yeah my dog is an insult yeah he's your
father he's a father but he's busted but
he's used to London itself did he bust
in it in in another dog he did yeah well
then he's not a [ __ ] insult well he
yeah but dogs are you frosted if you're
a doll no and you've busted in another
dog I know but you're not an answer I
know that but one fire ruined it by
exposing that butters as a father he
said that and it upset me too and the
truth is I didn't even know why it upset
me because what I was like what he's
saying is you're gonna it's bad yeah
you're intuitive yeah yeah
Coppola Oh crapola so I thought that was
so funny when I was [ __ ] nine or
whatever killed boy oh boy
city honest say that every time I come
now yeah oh boy oh boy oh boy and then
say crap old after I do yeah that's a
good idea
I think so when did it come out city
under siege oh is that the like the
actual title like police academy academy
city under siege Wow Pace Academy saw
drunk the way set up piece
Academy 1989 so I was not I was nein
nein nein 1989 I was I was nine I was
drunk I was nine so there we go I
[ __ ] said it and I knew it that's
[ __ ] amazing you call this buddy well
the thing was I was like you know how I
thought I maybe I was nine it was like
what at what point in my life would I
think that crapola is funny and I was
like nine I honestly I would laugh at
that now yeah I would too but for a
different [ __ ] Rhea okay yeah yeah
yeah do I love [ __ ] from like the late
80s and early 90s like TV movies I know
me today
I think it's because you I think it's
because probably we grew up then I think
oh yeah for sure like when like like
Drake came out with a [ __ ] this is
hilarious but Drake yesterday or two
days ago came out with like a [ __ ] or
a week ago I don't know when this is
gonna air but came out with a greatest
hits album and it's like well you don't
have to do that anymore because of
[ __ ] Spotify yes totally so but he
did and people are like wow it's
bringing me back and they love the music
extra because they grew up with it in
2012 now they're all [ __ ] twenty
right but like you love it extra because
you grew up with it right right and
that's what crapple is but also looking
back like an early 90s movie they will
be like a guy being like - like a really
like attractive woman and it'll be like
you got to lose some weight I don't want
to be married to a whale yeah yeah you
know and like the context isn't like
what a piece of [ __ ] right it's just
like a scene right and you're just like
oh my god the world is different you
know I mean the world certainly is
different yeah it's like calling your
wife a whale with like a smile yeah it
was like chilling back then yeah and I
mean I stopped doing that I had to stop
yeah well once you know I had to stop
calling my wife your wife well yeah
so yeah remember this though I wanted to
talk because we love this video I think
I know what's coming
yeah this is gonna live it Quentin
Tarantino's on camera man [ __ ]
goddamn how much does he okay yeah
how much does he deeply regret and his
like after he does it it's like oh no
okay I gotta brush it okay I forget it I
haven't seen so much
what's going on here nose my nose is
going on here yeah yeah what's going on
here what are you doing what are you
doing here not to talk to me
what are you doing don't do that again
I am fat rules actually go how'd he get
so far understand how he gets so far I'm
sorry
yeah are you oh yeah so your ass up and
down this yeah you know what these
greatest film couldn't turn guys ever
made
I'm sorry he's the [ __ ] like she just is
the [ __ ] dude like just that he's
wearing that is already like you're the
[ __ ] let me tell you something man I
agree with everything that happened here
where's it going I don't know where did
he come from was definitely in Utah yeah
but also like where is he going
look how did it get the finger placement
yeah what's going on here know what's
going on here like he's [ __ ] addition
yeah a magician no he this is I'm happy
that he slapped him I don't I don't
think he's sad to my thing he slapped
the camera yeah okay I'm happy he did
that he shouldn't slap the guy's face
obviously but you guys shouldn't just be
in his face - and of course of course
right I think that if a guy is in your
face filming you yeah
it is it should be a rule it is okay to
slap the camera out of the person it is
you're right American right to slap that
out of you you shouldn't ever physically
assault someone but I think it's okay if
a guy has a camera on somebody's face on
you know what's the word know what
unsolicited yeah if it's like yeah
exactly and you're just you have it it's
oak you basically have signed this
contract uh it's okay for me to get
smacked at it
it's like they've broken the contract
like people are constantly not knowing
the rules and if you don't know the
rules and you break the rule like yeah
all bets are off too right I'm gonna
slap that [ __ ] out of your [ __ ] right
right right and I hope it break right
now
also but in the video how does the
person get so [ __ ] far away but
Quinton gets far but he he slaps him and
then suddenly there's like a football
field between is there a cut no there's
not a cut right I mean unless they cut
it afterwards it's unbeliev you after
watches it expect Tarantino stops the
cameraman
if you're watching the video pocket you
can see it but he slaps the camera out
of the hit and it's like it's like he's
the flash all of a sudden he's [ __ ]
20 feet away yes yeah it's really weird
yeah oh it makes it way funnier and then
and then it man and when he does that
thing it's how I nobody look if you're
here I also that's a [ __ ] good
impression thank you
why the [ __ ] like yeah now you know what
I'm doing that's so good I actually
disagree with you that he feels bad
feels bad he's like nervous cuz it's on
camera he slapped somebody I disagree
with that too I what about after and you
know I think what you're doing is
coiling up as a snake and and I might
have to do something else here oh I
think he's like man right I'm acting
like cool I'm gonna lure him in and I'm
gonna [ __ ] cuz I might I might fight
this guy I think that's what he's doing
I don't think that what you're saying is
right play the tape again I appreciate
you saying that
what's going on here put that down
what's going on here
what do you know good what are you doing
Gigi can you not talk to me what are you
doing now he's a camera phone how is it
that far away
he's so far you must ran what Sorrell
hates me this is [ __ ] you wanna hit
me yeah [ __ ] yeah but by the way that
should be in a court of law is like well
you said hit him yeah yeah yeah I agree
with that too yeah that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing so here we go snakes so
much tougher because that's what the
snake does it's like okay look just come
by I'm just part of the bush
that's what's do it I'm just parted by
squirrel but that's what he's already
hit him I know I understand but it was
like a love it was like a [ __ ] smack
out of the thing I'm gonna choke the
[ __ ] out of him and that's all good like
luring him in a hundred percent disagree
but I like yours better so let's just go
is you know why I know he's coiling no I
don't because he sipped his coffee there
is no [ __ ] way this is good but he
would sip his coffee at this moment
unless he was like look I'm just gonna
act natural everything so I I agree with
that it's a high tension it's a I agree
with that what I think is he's like I
don't want this guy to like report yeah
and he's like no you know it's all fine
I'm so chill yeah I'm actually just
gonna sip I'm not even gonna punch I'm
not gonna yack
I'm gonna sip and like now we could be
we could be like yeah no I I but you
know Quentin Tarantino you know how he
thinks about things yeah you know he
hates this guy and and in he thinks
there's he thinks basically like I
should be able to beat the [ __ ] out of
this guy yeah he should I should beat
this guy he should yeah and I saw I
think that I think that my way is right
it's also way funnier well here's the
thing whether you're right or not yeah I
like yeah it's a better that yeah so I
believe that Matt's like anything that
can be better
it's not true that's the thing without
less it again is now it's not sinking
someone is amazing exhale I'm starting
yeah
are you oh you so you're not just a guy
from Russia paparazzi guy always going
like this extra - yeah yeah he's selling
it this is the WWE yeah he definitely is
into that [ __ ] yeah yeah you filming
yeah but that was up I'd be whooping
your ass up and down this right here
there's the raddest [ __ ] thing
anyone's ever done to say that to get
clarification and then be like oh right
because if that were true I'd be whoopin
your ass up and down the street and then
to turn around walk away from a
Starbucks up with street with that puffy
raccoon do jacket I'll get the where I
pause where I paused it look I have a
wild animal see dude dude he yeah yeah
because if that were off if that cameras
I was off I'd be whipping it whooping
your ass up and down this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that is a soda water he's a
great writer just gonna say that yeah
she's already to say it I've been in
this situation in my head 90 15 minutes
right right right yeah so I said the
coffee deletes a copy oh dude block god
yeah he's [ __ ] funny I'll [ __ ]
love Tarantino do it he was at the
Comedy Store once yeah and I [ __ ] ate
[ __ ] oh really yeah it was so long ago I
was like I want to go out for a Quinn 32
maybe he'll put me in the next one just
so longer than I ate [ __ ] it's our ne
and yeah it's O
okay I mean I'm sure he doesn't even
[ __ ] know who I am still but he was
just like yeah you know eat man oh you
[ __ ] Bob thn and walked away with a
big puffy jacket
that's all good eh n HN [ __ ] I mean I've
seen that video three hundred times you
know I mean how many views does a video
like that have not enough whatever then
yeah because that was one of those
things that kind of went viral before
people really give a [ __ ] about viral
stuff yeah it should be more me know how
many fuses I have for mil oh that's a
lot [ __ ] looks a lot wow he's just a
lot i think he's doing so much Jerrod
Carmichael yeah I think I think like
some I think I read I can't remember
what it is but that's very [ __ ] cool
yeah yeah he's just I don't like his
[ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] yeah nah that's the
thing though it's like he's one of those
guys that and I've never not liked one
of his things but like I haven't seen
all the things but uh I'm sure he you
know everybody makes bad [ __ ] movies
but like it's such a short it's like
make a choice you know yeah and he's
making such a choice that it's just
[ __ ] awesome it's yeah it's so it's
he's so him that's yeah but someone has
so themselves its I even if I don't like
it I like it you know because I'm like
that person is doing the [ __ ] hook
what you just did I don't know but that
won't strengthen they're just so
themselves and gonna go all the [ __ ]
way with it and he's like the most that
but yeah right now like like Jim
Carrey's that way like he just found is
so funny because you make such a choice
and commits to it yeah yeah yeah there
was one I'm never gonna remember this
but he did you Jim Carrey thing I
watched the clip of him doing that do
not go in there oh yeah and I was think
about like on a page that is just yeah
yeah yeah I know I know him doing it is
the funniest thing carries I I don't I
don't understand how I can't understand
how good he is yeah at doing the most
ridiculous [ __ ] and it's funny I it's so
hard
to do that it's so hard to commit that
much and still be funny yeah I think we
talked about you here the last time we
did we did we did [ __ ] love Jim
Carrey so much yeah I do love him so
much
what's that movie where there's there's
one vid movie where a guy this is guy
dude I know movies burn oh yeah all
right bro I just know a movie where a
guy opens of opens the door to something
and he goes oh any faints Jim Carrey
don't know it's not Jim Carrey I put on
my Instagram once this guy falls down
and III that's all I know
Wow and all I remember is the manager at
The Comedy Store thinks it's funny and
remembers the movie I wanna do that's a
bad story yeah I'm gonna text him you
know what I mean yeah that story's like
really bad yeah it doesn't even have
them I don't you know I know I know it
literally has only a beginning yeah and
a vague one I'm gonna what was the movie
where the guy I'm gonna text him right
now falls down and I can't hurt me know
how to describe it and it was so funny
ladies does he need to know what was
that 80s movie yeah 80s movie to
remember [ __ ] when we were watching
vice versa not vice versa what was the
one was if I first we were watching with
dad when we were kids and I was like
this is so 80s and dad was like yes
exaggerate don't know how to spell it
oh wow I do but I don't want it okay so
exaggerated you know yeah true and he
said confused he said what's a DS that
and we were like ATS yeah [ __ ] the
word and time period of the movie and I
was like what's that see so dad and we
were like what's wrong with your brain
yeah no no it's so it went it was like
so 80s we were said something right or
the movie was so 80s or the movie was so
eighties in it I said you said Oh 80s
and you were like I know yes so 80s and
he goes like that anyway he was like
acting like huh cool yeah and then right
like what's right what
oh yeah he said what Sadie yes and we
were like what nothing like no 80s and
then he goes oh oh and then we were like
do you get what we're saying he said
what's a tease yeah yeah yeah and we
were like a tease like the year yeah fix
your brain yeah yeah yeah and we and now
we always say what Sadie's yeah we
always say also - not it was so 80 I
know the movie was so aged so like do
the work of connecting things right yeah
that is though yeah that's so him what's
ad so there's a but I love having that
[ __ ] I love you never know when some
shits gonna like be with you for the
rest I always talk about this yeah yeah
you I love this you never know some
shits gonna be with you for the rest of
your life and then it happens and then
you always talk about it I love those
moments because you never know they're
gonna happen and now you have it with
your freezer and it's a happy accident I
have the worst memory but there's like a
handful of things like that that I
remember that you remember to happen he
remembered it he just texted me back
dude it's the movie cuffs
dude cuffs okay cuffs starring Christian
Slater I think of that movie a lot
because there's a play on words that he
says in that movie and it's you know
that expression things just people to
see things to do people to see you know
he says oh yes yes yes yes people to do
yes things to see like he's gonna [ __ ] a
lot of people you know I mean like yes
yes yes yes yes that's which is the
raddest thing that is the raddest thing
yeah yeah yeah okay okay I gotta find
this video because this is the greatest
greatest example of what we're talking
about Jim Carrey does right this is the
greatest example of of this [ __ ]
well that shot so [ __ ] amazing this
is so funny
and this guy went for it and I couldn't
believe they're gonna find it I don't
know I mean you said you find everything
on the internet so you putting me yeah
this is you oh yeah well put in maybe
cuffs something specific like got movie
guy falls down pratfall opens door
coughs the guy opens the door and he
gets away
fall down but no that's not it
oh he's he was [ __ ] look at it later
dude
this is that that's it this is gonna be
a is this it no that's not it Oh sewed
was so 80s Wow I mean also be already
ready what to shoot him fast yeah um
sure was coughs yeah he said was cuffs
I'm looking for I'm looking I'm law this
movie's amazing I'm watching this
tonight I gotta find this video before
we are done okay
pratfall proud to watch this scene from
cuffs how do you spell pratfall just the
way you think it is 2 1 T but the Chris
Pratt is a thing now and now I do that
it's just one labelled a prat that's the
[ __ ] line I think well as I'm Ricky
Gervais in the original office I guess I
could look up the cast here and find a
guy that would that did it I am deep
e-comm what do you that is that it oh
wow ok ok ok ok [ __ ] you Oh however they
tell you that it's hilarious like I know
cuffs
get ready little arrow yes yep ok ok I
got I got well if it's a Chris D'Elia
like you posted this because you love it
well this is put up 11 okay don't don't
play I wanna get this yeah I think this
is it okay this is so I mean how many
hilarious do reactions can there be in
cuffs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy when
I saw that I got a sitting okay when I
saw this this you would diet that I must
have liked this was a choice first of
all the fact that 11 seconds is just a
thought yeah this is the choice I'm
gonna make the [ __ ] goddamn boulder
balls you have to have those Armando is
not the star by the way he's the guy in
the right yeah I mean imagine being the
director being like you don't know what
he's gonna do yeah and you'd have to
take the rest of the day off because
he's gonna be a [ __ ] masterpiece now
unbelievable
so alright so I'm gonna play it again
and then and then for the fact that it's
to make it funny banker that's your
banker Wow dude that is a genius thing
to do and he keeps his arms up why is
just why do his arms go up
why do his arms go up that's actually
too funny I can't even laugh at it I
know you're genius I feel like if Jim
Carrey saw that he'd be like oh wow
great yeah for sure yeah we should show
him yeah I thought is really my scene
you know that was your banker Christian
Slater's hey I know dude Christmas
lady's hair is the most ruling as asset
there ever was in 1992 yeah [ __ ] man so
funny alright well that's good I mean we
did 100 in 16 minutes we're good babies
right maybe I should just do the last
part here
right
download the cash app from the App Store
or Google Play market you could download
my app too if you want get the merch
chris d'elia calm and subscribe to the
youtube channel thanks so much for
having my bro Matt D'Elia on the podcast
you got to check out his podcast called
Matt D'Elia is confused it talks about a
lot of stuff that we interviews those
guys from queueing on and also uh Bob
Larson did a really good and who else
have you had on tea party former tea
party congressman joe walsh we've had
some artists on to talk about getting
cancelled and [ __ ] like that and yes
just kind of like a wide array of things
that i'm like what the [ __ ] going on
social in the world yeah so subscribe to
his podcast definitely and check it out
and listen it's it's great its own spot
of Spotify stitcher Google Play or for
all the [ __ ] whatever [ __ ] yeah
everywhere you go podcasts so that's it
thanks a lot and I'll see you soon San
Diego and I'll see you soon all the
other allele applies to San Jose San
Jose and Vegas and Peoria Santa Barbara
Riverside and I'll wait didn't we do
anyone Oh Houston in El Paso Houston's
going to sell out soon so get those
tickets Houston and that's it join me
new join me New Year's Eve in Chicago
alright thanks for babies and remember
travel
[Music]